introduced us we are both part of the
nlp group here at city
and
we are going to present you today a work
that we did on
implementing different approaches for uh
augmentation
so just a few words on our on our nlp uh
so just sorry a quick overview of of the
of what we are going to talk about today
we are going to say a few words about
our nlp group and the challenges that
some of the challenges that we have
and then we will briefly uh
talk about the data annotation process
here in city and then we will present
you two
out of several approaches that we use
for doing data augmentation and lastly
we will present you
a model that we train on the augmented
data and its results
so our main goal as a as as an n p group
here at city is actually to facilitate
and simplify daily basis tasks that
bankers do
much of the work is being done manually
and much of it is a very specific work
and we would like to help them and and
do it by doing it automatically and
using some nlp tools
um
so just to put you in the context hilar
already mentioned it but uh
city is one of the biggest banks in the
world it is it is spreaded worldwide it
is a huge corporation it has branches
all over in almost every country
so for us as data scientists especially
as as a nlp people this is a great
opportunity because
there are many business units so there
are many documents that are being uh
stored and processed and created on a
daily basis so it's it's like a great
potential of having really great and
interesting and diverse data and doing
some really cool stuff with it
uh
okay uh so i will present you one of
many tasks that we are
dealing with in our group and one of
them is is information extraction
well there are like i said many types of
documents and
here we would like to extract certain
relevant information for the bankers and
by doing it automatically
so uh
i just have to mention that the data
comes in very different formats so some
of the documents are a
formal pdf some of the documents are
written email or email correspondence
some of the documents are are
very structured forms
so
those tasks that maybe
may seem trivial to us as human readers
can be
untrivial or a bit tricky when we're
trying to optimize them
so i will show now an example of one of
the documents that we have to work on of
course it is blurred because this is a
bank and i can't show you the data
itself but a document can contain many
pages and we have to search for certain
relevant information for example we need
to to find a company name or we need to
find the the company address or we need
to find uh
the date uh but usually we don't want to
just find a date or a company name or
address it should usually come with a
certain context
um
so
okay so how do we do that
well this is the very naive and basic
pipeline when we're trying to solve
a np problem so we need the label data
then we can do just a few pre-processing
methods on it and
then we can just put it as an input to
one of the greatest state of the of the
art models that exist today and we we
should be happy
but uh
as you're probably guessing it is not
that easy uh well the first bottleneck
that we're tackling
is in the first stage
where we actually need to get the data
so as i said before there is tons of
data in cd but cd is a bank and most of
the data is confidential and so we have
very limited access to it and even when
we do have some access to some of the
data we need domain expert uh to to
annotate it well and to to give us the
the correct labels and this resource is
also very limited
okay so just a few words about the data
and the data annotation process
well
we are asking usually the domain expert
to spend
as much time as they can which is
usually not a lot
by doing some annotation on on the data
and then
we're using data augmentation
that
actually the goal is to make this small
data set larger and and versatile enough
so we can and make a robust we can make
a robust model and then we just uh give
it as an input to to the model that
we're using we usually we train it and
then we can use some methodology
methodology that's called active
learning so this is a methodology that
helps us
pick the
the relevant new samples that we would
like uh the domain expert to focus on
and
because we want to optimize the time
that they are spending on it and then we
can just do this cycle again and again
okay so what that augmentation really
means uh that augmentation is it's a
method that uh
we're using
uh for creating a larger data set from
an existing data set but by either
modifying it
or by uh or by creating a new synthetic
data
but when we're doing that we should keep
in mind that
the main goal is not just to make the
data set larger but we need to make it
as as versatile as possible and we would
would like to keep them
the same high quality of the labeling
and also we would like to to
to keep the same original meaning so
so the labeling won't be uh
won't change
okay so
now to the interesting part uh
how did how did we do that so i again we
will present you of the approaches that
we're using here the first approach is a
textual augmentation where the input is
actually a sentence it's a plain text
okay
so i'm going to present now four of the
augmenters that we've implemented and
actually each augmenter
has a different responsibility it does a
different
use it uses different methodology for
doing the augmentation the modification
so uh the first augmented the resource
segmenter is inventor that we give it
some
some file that contains any alternative
value
for a certain entity
so that means that in a sentence we
would like to replace certain
words that have certain features in in
this example we would like to to
modify all words that represent animals
so we give the augmenter
an input file that contains list of all
animals name and it just speaks randomly
any animal name and and place it
and replace the original words
the sentence might change
we change the world but
but still uh
we we want to make the this is the whole
point we want to make new sentence that
but we don't want to make the same
sentence so we decide how how much we
would like to change it i mean this is
this is why this is a recent fight you
can decide which
animal list for example you would like
to say
he was fast as a rabbit
and change it to his was fast as an
elephant
yeah but but again it depends on what
you're trying to do
yeah if you're doing it randomly
no you decide what is the
vocabulary
yeah exactly and besides doing it
randomly just one of the methodology we
can there are there are other
implementations but this is the most
naive and simple one
okay so another augmenter that we've
implemented here is the data augmenter
in this augmenter we just
take the part of the text that
represents a date so here is the 14th
july in 2019 and we just replace it
with a random date format that we gather
from all kind of documents that we've
processed so we just pick a random date
format and we generate a random date so
it can be
for example
only the year like 2015 or it can be
a day that contains
words and numbers
uh the next augmented that we're using
here is the mask language model
augmenter
this augmenter uses a birth base
language model and
again we we decided as user what kind i
mean what words with what feature we
would like to replace and then we just
so we can decide for example that in the
sentence we would like to to replace all
nouns or or verbs or all other words
that have a specific features and we
just
mask them put it as an input to the to
the language model to the language model
and then we get the predictions
that uh by which we actually replace the
the original word so for example if we
will replace here the world awesome we
can get from the mask language model the
world
it's it's
amazing or it's fantastic or it's great
okay in the last uh augmenter that i'm
going to show you here is the random
noise augmenter
in this augmenter we actually used
a text attack implementation text attack
is one of the open source libraries that
exists
and we just this segment or what he does
it just enters randomly typos ver a
common common typos from keyboards or
just drops randomly one of the
characters in the in the sentence so you
see that for the what it drops the a or
from the word create it drops the t
right and here it drops the u okay
so how actually this whole process goes
uh we decide which augmenters we would
like to use
and in which order
and so given an input sentence the the
whole pipeline actually finally outputs
a list of different sentences that conde
contain each sentence contain different
uh combination of modifications that
were done by the augmenters that which
we've chosen to use so if we are using
now the resource augmenters of the
animals that i've shown you before
and also the mlm augmented so one of the
output can be
this sentence where the world
fox was replaced by wolf and the world
dog was replaced by
by a cat but also
the mlm augmenter added another
modification to the sentence where it
replaces the world jumps by climbs
okay and this is another example where
one of the outputs would be only the
output of of one of the augmenters
okay and
and or we can get different values from
these augmenters
so i will show you now a real uh real
life
uh example so we have an input sentence
that contains a
that contains a name of a financial
institution
uh american national you see the
sentence the company name is american
national bank uh the date of
announcement is 13 july
2020 so we we would like to use the data
mentor and to replace uh the financial
institution by any other financial
institution from a given resource that
contains names of all financial
institutions like we did in the with the
animal case so
one of the outputs would be uh the
replacement of the of the name of the
institution and the replacement of the
of the date
and another in output sentence would be
a sentence that also contains the
modifications that were made by the mlm
augmenter so you see that it modified
the word date to time and the world
announcement to issue
or we can have also the modification
that is made by the random noise
augmenter that where he entered the typo
in the announcement word or
dropped the e in the d word and some
added some more typos in the date
so finally
what we are actually getting in this in
this pipeline we are
giving it an input
uh one sentence where we
uh
where we can actually label which each
world with different features and we can
uh decide we can configure which
augmenters we would like to
to use
and on which uh fit and we on which
feature we would like it to be to be to
work on to do the modifications and then
the output would be a list of different
sentences that each of them contains
different combination of
of augmentation
okay and so just last word uh
today there exists several uh
open source libraries that do that
augmentation we can use text attack for
that augmentation or there is also npr
and there are several others
okay
hi everyone my name is elon so i will
continue to talk about layout data
augmentation so this is very similar to
text augmentation but this time we have
another modality which is the layout so
what do we mean by layout
so imagine we have this document now
this document is a scanned image so it's
no text right we have to process it in
some some sort of way like ocr as we can
see and then we have the text with the
layout so what is the layout actually
it's only the bounding box around each
one of the text box now pay pay
attention that you don't really get the
text as plain text or suspense or
something nice you just get
um dots over the documents you don't
really know for example that
in program budgets
program budget code is a span you just
get program code and budget right and
you can also have it splitted like
budget is bad jet and the ocr doesn't
know that so we have many complications
and we see that in a minute so what
we'll have is stacks and bounding box
which is the ocr token
okay so this is a real example again
this is a document which is blurred
because of the confidential
you know that so actually what we see
here is three types of um data we
extract so the first one is key values
we have for example here name and the
value of the name some company name we
have check boxes
and we also have fill in text which is
paragraph with lines and the clients
just send us pdfs with signs or
something like that or filled in um
country name or date or stuff like that
so how does the pipeline looks like
quite reasonably and you get the pdf for
the image it's scanned image and then we
process it using ocr we call it our
surplus plus because we have our own
custom
extension for example we extract lines
we extract tables we extract images and
some other kinds of stuff
and then we can move to the information
structure
now the data augmentation comes in
between so instead of
on the text level we work on the text
level with the layout combined now we
must produce
um
stuff that looks real
and we cannot lie so for example the
what you mentioned with the elephants
now we have another complication because
it's not only the text that can be
current we only need we need also the
layout to be current so
just to
to present some of the complexity of the
task itself of the information
extraction the first one is the
horizontal context this looks quite
trivial for us as humans as the key is
on the left and then double dots and you
have the value on the right but
sometimes it's a little bit more
complicated
for example here you see vertical top
context i mean why is it why is this
different from this one we need to
distinguish between the two
another example would be the multi-line
so multi-line is key and value but we
need to understand that it's not only
key and value one against the other it
can be multi-line also the key can be
multilined out plenty of
really weird stuff that you see in
documents and we just accept them
because we are humans but the machine
cannot really process them quite well um
another one and there are many more but
this is just to get you into the
details so checkboxes checklists are
quite complicated and you can have them
multiply checked some are empty you can
also have extra data for example here
you have another text that can be filled
by the client so many complexities but
this is the task
so how do we solve that
we want that augmentation
um to work not only on the text but also
on the layout so what we do is take a
real example this is not a real example
but i had to show you something in high
resolution to understand
how it looks like so for example if we
zoom in on this
um this portion of the document
um we have here a shifted version so we
have many types of shifts for example we
have shifts between the key and the
value which can be here a little bit
tighter we can also have the values
spreaded differently and there are many
creative stuff that our clients like to
insert for us
and also it is a shift here if you see
the vertical shift now this is not
trivial again because the count account
sid is founded next to the company ltd
but we know that this is not true right
so it's quite complicated so the first
one is shift
and another one which we represent is
the resizing so because it's scanned
sometimes the font a little bit looks
different there are noises there are
resizing skews all kind of that
and there are many more for example you
have a noise in ocr sometimes the ocr
just produce things that are not true
and can be also many
lines over there scanned so it doesn't
really look always pretty and but this
is how we augment both the text and the
layout complications
so eventually we have something like
that we take only a few 100 is quite a
exaggeration we have only like 10 of
them or something like that because we
don't need to frustrate our people and
then we have only a few of them and we
make them thousands but still diverse
and coherent both textual wise and
layout wise
and we have a huge data set to train
some model on it so this is the
documentation we use
and just in a word to get you curious
and if you want you can ask questions
and thoughts so what models do we use so
just if you want to to get a little bit
more familiar with the
models so bert i'm guessing most of you
already know it accepts text and the
position in the sentence what we call a
one dimensional positional encoding and
then you get contextualized vectors so
this might looks already known for us
what we need now is a two-dimensional
positional encoding and this is the main
difference between bert and leotelem and
from that we also
progress to weber creed for example it's
only one of out of many which also
combine the modality of the image for
example lines tables and checkboxes
stuff like that
so that's only in a brief about the
models
and some results so this is only a
single task we have many of them and
this is also a work in focus but just to
to show you the the power um of that
augmentation even a simple one
so when we use it without augmentation
on less than 100 documents we get quite
poor results we cannot be satisfied by
90. we need like 95 even 100 sometimes
even if it's overfitted because it's a
bank you cannot do mistakes
so
before augmentation is quite low but
when we add some augmentation
it looks much better
and just to show that we don't really
overfit to something specific we also
show results of out of domain so if you
take the same model trained on the first
data with augmentation and take to
inference another data set we still get
quite good results now if we want we can
also improve that we just look at the
other dataset and adjust it with another
documentation and documentation is quite
simple so it works for
four best
what is the method that you're showing
here
so that's f1 of name identity
recognition
it's one of the tasks and yeah thanks
it's up above
okay so to summarize we showed you only
a really tiny portion of our ecosystem
here so we have many challenges and we
don't have access to all the data and
when we have when we have only little of
that
um we design that augmentation as one of
the strongest strategies next to the
active learning which we don't talk here
and eventually we just improve our
models to make products which allow
achieve
95 maybe more because we cannot have
less than that
so
that's it thank you